here's the thing though
if it's a watch history if the person's
in a vertical gardening
and you put out a video on the top 10
craziest moments from minecraft it
doesn't matter if all the video
performance is off the charts that user
has no interest in that topic
right so this is how these things stack
together the youtube algorithm is not
just pushing your video to just anybody
it's trying to again get your video in
front of the right people and it's more
about actually them understanding the
user and then pulling videos that that
user has indicated they want to watch
are you trying to figure out the youtube
algorithm is it a mystery to you and you
just want to figure out what is this
thing and how do i use it to my
advantage well in today's episode we are
taking questions from the think media
community we posted on social media and
we grabbed your questions all about the
youtube algorithm my name is heather
torres and i am your host of the think
media podcast the number one podcast to
help you grow your influence on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high profit online business
i'm excited to jump into your questions
and i want to thank you for answering
them over on social media we posted on
the community tab on youtube over on
instagram and on facebook so if you're
not following us on social make sure you
do that next you can follow us at
official think media on instagram and
then you can follow sean or just the
youtube channel um if you want to be a
part of these types of episodes this
episode is also brought to you by our
upcoming free youtube class i'll tell
you more about that at the end but let's
jump into today's featured question
[Music]
so what even is the youtube algorithm
man you know what's so funny about the
youtube algorithm is it seems like this
super mysterious thing like no one can
be told what the matrix is
you have to see it for yourself like if
you don't take the red pill or the blue
pill then you're not going to get the
revelation of the secret code inside of
the youtube algorithm is it the wizard
of oz who's hiding behind the curtain
who's working at youtube pulling the
levers you know is it ancient aliens
like when you look at the
angle of the egyptian pyramids and you
realize like that's how they discovered
the angle of the youtube algorithm
that's kind of how it feels i mean you
see different people's youtube videos
unlocking the youtube algorithm decoding
the youtube algorithm the mystery of the
youtube algorithm solved well is it
possible to actually demystify some of
the mystery around the youtube algorithm
i think it is and i think to the degree
that you understand how youtube works
you can then structure your content to
please the youtube algorithm
uh wizard of oz to make him happy so
that he promotes your videos to the ends
of the earth and so uh there's a lot of
data and distinctions in this video that
i want to share with you and just to
kind of try to make something that's
pretty complex simple so let's dive into
this so what is the youtube algorithm
well ultimately it's a recommendation
system
that decides which video
which videos youtube suggests to the 2.3
billion monthly active users so that's
updated data there's 2.3 billion
people that have a gmail account that
are logged into youtube that access the
platform at least once a month
the viewership of youtube is much larger
because not everybody has that youtube
account
so the youtube algorithm's goal
is to serve up basically individual
suggestions it's trying to categorize
understand and satisfy viewers youtube
wants to win in the landscape of all
these other options you could be
watching netflix you could be watching
hulu you could be doing anything else
and youtube wants your attention
so it's trying to make the viewer happy
by recommending videos and suggesting
videos
to
its users and viewers
youtube's goal is to get users onto
youtube
and of course to do that that's from
their brand from the options of content
for you considering youtube being a
destination or even external traffic of
some kind but then ultimately they want
to keep you on youtube that's youtube's
one-two punch how do i get you on to
youtube watching content but not just
for like a little quick 60-second funny
cat video lunch break how do i actually
keep you on youtube for hours maybe
hours every day
competing with maybe traditional forms
of media or ott
type of stuff like netflix and hulu and
how do i actually get the viewers
attention keep satisfying them with
content so this is why tweaking the
algorithm
on their site is so important because if
you keep getting videos you like if you
finish a video and it just plays the
next video that you're like i don't even
know i wanted to watch this have you
ever gone to that rabbit hole have you
ever gone down that conspiracy rabbit
hole on youtube it's kind of like h
aliens right all of a sudden you're like
i don't even know where i am dude like i
i this pint of ben jerry's is gone like
i just drank like a liter of diet coke
and i am an hour and 45 minutes in to
some really niche data about how jay-z
and beyonce are in the illuminati like
where even am i i need to go up for a
walk i need some sunlight the youtube
algorithm it's serving you content it's
it's taking you down
uh a you know a rabbit trail and so
this is an important quote
the youtube algorithm
isn't
trying to find viewers for your videos
it's trying to find
videos to satisfy youtube users
people really make this mistake you'd be
surprised how much algorithm blame there
is i think the algorithm's broken it's
my videos are not getting distributed no
your videos just have really gone
downhill and you've been to repeating
yourself a lot like i just think the
algorithm is broke i'm being shadow
banned you're not being shadow banned
it's like the co your content is just
not is giving signals people aren't
clicking on it or they're not sticking
with it in your average view duration
and i hear somebody saying yeah well
actually no my my channel is getting
shadow banned because in one obscure
thing of doing conservative news maybe
maybe but you'd be surprised
whether no matter what your political
beliefs are liberal you know republican
conservative there's massive channels
that are on both camps that are crushing
it all the time of course is there
censorship is there sure but my point is
this we usually are overly
blaming the platform blaming the
algorithm blaming youtube when by the
way that's something that's out of your
control what is in your control is you
controlling your own content and the
problem is a lot of us can fall into in
a way being selfish and we actually
think the algorithm's goal
is to find viewers for our videos like
my videos are so good dude my content is
so good youtube's job is to go out and
find some people for me where are my
people where are my viewers where are my
subscribers
[Music]
me remember that scene from whatever
there's like the birds i think that was
finding nemo listen me like going out
and trying to find
viewers for your videos that's not what
they're doing listen the youtube
algorithm
is trying to find videos for their users
they're trying to study and by the way
this is robots doing things like this
there's there's not enough humans in the
world
to even be able to manage every bit of
videos that are uploaded to youtube
so they have to create an algorithm to
study what satisfies viewers what do
people watch what is getting watch time
what's getting click-through rate people
fill out surveys people click the like
button people leave comments and they're
they're just taking all these data
points trying to serve you better videos
and here's the thing hopefully the
algorithm is improving i think it is the
more that youtube understands you
youtube wants to bring you videos it's
not trying to take you somewhere else to
give you to show you videos you don't
want to watch
it's trying to discern your behaviors
your tastes your preferences to say
what's going to keep you on the platform
for as long as possible and if they can
endlessly feed you content
like the humans
in the wally movie just sitting there
just constantly being fed the content
you know i don't know if that's a
healthy state that's youtube's goal like
just like literally 24 hours a day i'm
just
i got endless entertainment here i love
every one of these keep them coming i
don't even need to go outside anymore
like there's plenty of content coming my
way but hear me
youtube's algorithm isn't trying to find
viewers for your videos it's trying to
find videos
to satisfy youtube users
so how does the youtube algorithm work
it works
through their discovery systems
and the three big ones is
youtube's homepage so the question is
what videos
are on youtube's homepage
the number one way you watch content
is you log into your app or you get on
desktop and right there on the home page
videos are being recommended to you
now think about this even if you're not
logged in
you pop onto youtube and right there on
the homepage there's some options that
they want you to click on think about
this you go to an airbnb
a vrbo
you get onto the smart tv there's no one
logged into youtube you open up youtube
maybe it's a fresh login like no one's
even been there no data has been
captured yet and there's some videos on
the home page it's a it's an invitation
to walk through door number one and
after about watching 10 videos youtube's
studying that ip address they're
studying whoever's watching content in
that moment this is why
if you jump on someone's smart tv i was
a at uh kyle anderson on the think media
team's house the other day and i jumped
on his youtube and i was like wow sketch
just kidding but i was like i was like
wow i'm actually
you get insight into a person's brain if
you go to their youtube homepage
because he actually he was part-time at
a church so i started seeing all these
cool like different praise and worship
videos all these different like pastors
he follows he's into cars i started
seeing different car content and i was
like man
this this car content he has a jeep he's
getting different stuff recommended to
him so
that content
how are home pages decided we'll answer
that question in in a second then the
question how what about youtube search
so you actually ask a question in the
youtube search bar what videos rank up
top that's another discovery system
you you come with a pointed question to
youtube
how do i start vertical gardening
tomatoes in an apartment boom you enter
that question it starts a journey so
what videos rank up top but youtube's
also listening to the question so
they'll start recommending you probably
vertical gardening videos
because you signaled youtube and
interest of yours whoever the person is
on the that side of the smartphone or
the smart tv or the computer and then
what videos is youtube suggesting a
viewer watch next
the three big ones will be like your
home page search and then suggest
suggested videos when a video ends
youtube auto plays the next video you
watch a video about vertical gardening
tomatoes in an apartment probably at the
end of the video they're gonna throw
another vertical gardening video at you
or they'll throw like a jimmy fallon
video at you just like some really top
level mass amounts of people
maybe are gonna watch this
clip of the news or clip of a comedian
or something else but the question is
what actually gets suggested at the end
of a video or as you're watching a video
on your mobile phone you're not fully
engaged so you're scrolling to see is
there anything else youtube's
recommending below this video i might
want to jump and go watch something else
like i kind of like this do you watch
youtube like me you kind of got you
don't fully dive in you got like your
toes in the pool but you're like
i'm gonna click on this and watch this
until i find something better you're
scrolling through suggested videos
minimize little video playing in the
corner of your smartphone you're like
i'm still surfing around the app looking
for my next thing
like what determines what youtube is
suggesting to you
so one of the things to know about the
youtube algorithm
is that in terms of decoding the youtube
algorithm 75 of youtube traffic
comes from recommendations
and everything else 25 percent is search
is
external traffic as other forms niche
forms of traffic so tapping into
youtube recommending your videos and
suggested in the homepage
is the game is the game so how sean how
how do we decode the youtube algorithm
how can i get my videos to be
recommended and shown to others
how does youtube actually determine
what videos it shows to users
one is watch history
is watch history
so this is relevant to your interest
based on your past behavior
so
the first thing
is realizing that the way the algorithm
works is it's going to keep serving up
videos based off
that user that person who's logged in or
that account that smart tv at airbnb
that's got like 14 people's preferences
all mixed together it's just a mess like
who what kind of content are we watching
here like there's been 14 people so
ultimately
what is the previous watch history
here's a tip
this is actually why it's super smart to
position your content in proven in
profitable niches what do i mean
it means that
you ask yourself
is vertical gardening a really solid
topic that people like and watch on
youtube the answer is yes
our guitar tutorials or gaming videos
but even more specifically
and if that's true here's another way to
put it
are people watching
other content creators that are creating
the content that i'm making that's a
good thing
competition is not why because when that
video ends
theoretically you do a good job of
creating good content you'll get
discovered because others are succeeding
because there's a hunger for more
content maybe from different
perspectives if somebody wants golf tips
and they find three golf creators they
like
they're watching their videos guess what
that person's watch history is saying
they like golf they want to watch golf
you bring something unique or different
to it your video eventually gets
recommended to them those channels help
you grow because they've already defined
viewer behavior
and you put out something creative
something unique you only need one video
to start really getting recommended and
that could bring a stream of new
discovery into you so that's how the
algorithm works is watch history
and the my question is
is your channel based around a clear
interest that real viewers want to watch
it's just a matter of time then if you
put out good content that your content
will probably start getting recommended
to them secondly video performance
so youtube
pushes videos
into the youtube algorithm based on a
couple things click through rate average
view duration average percentage viewed
likes dislikes and viewer surveys so
these are the big ones
and some carry even more weight than
others but ultimately you put out a
video to youtube
if they're going to show it to strangers
not subscribers if they're going to show
it to strangers the question becomes
how large of an audience
can we put this thumbnail and title in
front of
like if we were to put it imagine this
if we were to put this video on the home
page of all
2.3 billion
active users home pages by the way did
you know that there's basically 2.3
billion plus different home pages
everybody's homepage is different
because it's based on user behavior user
preference and data points
a lot of similarities and chances are
there's not a video in the world that
everyone on youtube cares about
just just imagine
if they were to put it on 2.3 billion
people's home pages
would people click on it
would the thumbnail grab their attention
would people click on it that's thing
one
and so if youtube keeps showing your
video to new people and new people keep
clicking on it
then they'll keep showing it to even
more people
but that's not the only metric if then
they don't just click on it but they
actually stay on it average view
duration
and average percentage viewed they don't
just stay on it they watch it till the
end average percentage viewed they watch
the video all the way to the end you put
out a five minute video
massive amounts of humans on planet
earth click on it
a large majority of those people watch
almost the entire thing average
percentage viewed
they click the like button hear me or
the dislike button engagement would be
equal in that case they could watch all
five minutes of a five minute video be
outraged click dislike but youtube would
say well
clearly this person like wanted the
information they're not happy about it
but it is still keeping them on the
platform
and then ultimately if you've ever seen
one of those viewer surveys and maybe
you've never seen one but i've seen them
on my smart tv i've seen them on my
desktop i've seen them on mobile
sometimes youtube wants you to actually
take a quick survey they push it to you
and they go
did that video you just watched from
casey neistat satisfy you i don't know
if that's the exact wording you know and
you're like it did a little bit it did a
lot it it it was super hot man i like
that video that was a great vlog
right and so
what youtube is just trying to track is
viewer satisfaction
if and and and let's stack these two
points together
if a video is the greatest video in the
world click-through rate off the charts
man average view duration incredible
people take a survey they go this
couldn't have been a better video i mean
this was better than a great steak or a
great double burger in and out man this
this video changed my life or a great
vegan falafel dude this video just
literally
and with the survey here's the thing
though
if it's a watch history if the person's
in a vertical gardening
and you put out a video on the top 10
craziest moments from minecraft it
doesn't matter if all the video
performance is off the charts that user
has no interest in that topic
right so this is how these things stack
together the youtube algorithm is not
just pushing your video to just anybody
it's trying to again get your video in
front of the right people and it's more
about actually them understanding the
user and then pulling videos that that
user has indicated they want to watch
makes sense so number one watch history
number two video performance number
three
other viewers like you so what you want
to begin to understand
is
back to the golf analogy what youtube is
discerning with the algorithm
is it saying okay
you have 10 000 subscribers on your golf
channel now
and some people aren't even in subscribe
but they watch almost every video you
upload because youtube keeps
recommending it to them
what youtube's
algorithm does and they write about this
and their white papers about it
is it says okay
the people who watch this channel so far
the people who watch your channel so far
what do we know about them
and uh based on your subscribers based
on the people who are actually giving
you watch time minutes even unsubscribed
viewers
what do we know about them and are there
other users on the platform
that indicate to us
mathematically by all these data points
that are also potentially going to
probably like that content as well and
youtube's really good at this
so it would kind of be like
if somebody was
into a particular kind of music so you
really like drake the hip-hop artist
and so you're watching drake's videos
then they could probably say okay well
there's other people who have indicated
that they like music videos but it's not
just that they like music videos what we
know about this person is they like
garth brooks and blake shelton i don't
know if we need to recommend them a
drake video they might we could try it
but like i don't know if they'll click
on it but if somebody likes drake they
go okay well maybe let's try to
recommend them that new kanye west video
and here are some other users who have
signified that they like watching hip
hop music videos makes sense so even
though maybe you've never discovered
a niche obscure wrapper that person's
music video might start to
get a little heat on it click through
rate average view iteration little likes
people like it
and people are they're studying viewers
of all kinds
so they start to suggest that video uh
to
those viewers as well and a video can go
viral it's the key to decoding the
algorithm and getting your videos to
go viral a good book on this
um that you wouldn't maybe even think of
is a book called tribes by seth godin
and again it goes back to this idea
of don't go trying to invent a new
community of people or trying to get
super creative if you tell me my youtube
channel is the only one in the world
there's no other youtube channels like
it it is for the most obscure thing and
there's probably not even people who
like this it's so unique i'm the most
unique it
tribes is not about creating a community
of people it's actually about joining a
pre-existing community of people for
example
do people listen to hip hop
music and watch
music videos of it they do and will they
want to listen to hip hop music and
watch other music videos a year from now
they probably will do people like to
vertical do vertical gardening and
here's the thing when you get into the
psychology
are some i'm going to stereotype here
and you actually need to think in
stereotypes if you're going to hack the
youtube algorithm
are sometimes those people that are
healthy-minded let's say is it is it
possible that people that are into
gardening are also into a plant-based
lifestyle it's probably pretty possible
is it possible that people that are into
gardening are also potentially into
kind of yoga it is possible are people
that are into gardening could they even
actually have
liberal
somewhat slanted views towards empathy
towards the planet as well which might
even influence what news they watch it's
certainly possible could people that are
into
uh you know vertical guard be interested
in certain types of clothing brands or
certain types of creators with certain
types of ideologies it's not just
possible it's likely
so to the degree seth godin would tell
us in the books book tribes and of
course we'll always link up the
resources and i highly recommend reading
it um
that book really just kind of goes into
okay
are you really clear
on your viewer persona are you really
clear not just on the demographics of
your ideal viewer but the psychographics
and are you understanding not even just
the clear niche that you're planning
your channel in but like the ancillary
mindset like the surrounding
kind of universe of youtube channels
that could be that could have
interest in those types of things my
friends this is how you start to decode
the youtube algorithm and you create
videos that could pull audiences from
adjacent niches into your world
deep man we're in that ancient aliens
bottom of the pyramid secret treasure
chest there's a mummy we just opened it
up like inside there's a gold chalice
and a ruby in there this is some
algorithm secrets like let's let's keep
going the final one
is
keywords plus performance
another distinction of how youtube works
is
keywords and metadata
now
in
2021 and beyond
keywords are not some secret code
that you just happen to national
treasurer enter the rights you know
ancient
uh you know hieroglyphs in the right
order and then like you know the stone
door opens and you run in and you grab
the thing and a giant boulder is
following you sean you're mixing
references listen
keywords
it's keywords plus performance so
everything we talked about video
performance click through rate and all
that stuff but keywords still matter
youtube wants to serve up especially
in search
but even in suggested they want to serve
up videos that satisfy the exact
interests of people
so if somebody if you got like hyper
niche if somebody was really into
keto but not dirty keto clean keto and
they were really into
intermittent fasting and they really got
into some of the distinctions there you
being very intentional with your titles
with your metadata which is your
descriptions tags carry less weight but
you might as well be
detailed and specific and all those
details to say hey youtube i'm really
answering specific questions here i'm
really reviewing specific products here
i'm really teaching specific skills here
i'm really getting clear in my keyword
research and my topic research
and
and i'm putting out content so that
these videos can satisfy viewers that
have specific questions these videos can
satisfy viewers that have specific pain
points and so
if you want more on that too that's what
we talk about on our
thinkmasterclass.com
specifically it's about actually how to
kind of hack the search-based angle of
the algorithm which i believe is still
to this day the absolute best way to
start growing your channel get your
first 1000 subs your first 10 000 subs
and to this day think media continues to
lean heavily into search-based content
that gets promoted by the algorithm and
suggested as well and it leads to
approaching four million views every
single month like clockwork if you want
to learn exactly how we do that and we
can't unpack all of that plus
if you want to see like watch over my
shoulder and watch me share my screen
and really break down in detail
how to grow your channel
with that method just check check out
thinkmasterclass.com
where you can see that but again watch
history video performance other viewers
like you and keywords that is how the
youtube algorithm is going to determine
what videos to show users and i
encourage you to the degree you
understand that continue to lean into
that i realize this has been kind of a
heady episode um but you will really
start creating better content that will
start getting better results on youtube
and as we land the plane
your action steps of the week
are two metrics to improve we've talked
about them before
and they're super powerful when it comes
to video performance what matters most
ctr and avd
as we land the plane two metrics to
improve click through rate and average
view duration because remember
the viewer can't even watch the video if
they don't click on the video if you
don't grab them with the topic and the
title and the thumbnail it doesn't even
matter what the content is so you got to
get that click-through rate up make sure
you're subscribed to the podcast as we
continue to
unfold different tactics and strategies
to help you with that and then
you can't actually the video will not be
recommended if you can't hold the
viewer's attention so click through rate
get the person to click
and then minutes matter most average
view duration
remember get one percent better with
every upload this is some overwhelming
information small tweaks lead to giant
peaks make your next upload your best
upload and keep making those minor
improvements you're going to be shocked
by how much progress you make on youtube
over the coming weeks months and even
years by focusing on just getting one
percent better with every upload
well that answered our featured question
of today all about the youtube algorithm
and remember the algorithm is always
changing youtube is always changing why
because their objective is to get as
many eyeballs on youtube for as long as
possible so they're there to serve up to
your audience so your job is to make
great content that people want to watch
over and over again i have some action
items and some questions for you and the
first one really is what analytics do
you need to go into and study on your
channel have you looked at your audience
retention rate have you looked at your
views and your clicks are you seeing
what people are actually watching and
where people are leaving you know
youtube actually gives us so much
information are you using it to the best
of your ability and if you want to go
deeper on how to grow on youtube or what
it looks like to actually start and
scale a youtube channel i'm excited
because we're hosting a free youtube
class i'm actually hosting it for you
and so you can register at
thinkmasterclass.com
teaching you how to get to your first
1000 subscribers and earn your first 1
000 on youtube and if you're an
introvert a newbie or an everyday person
this is right for you so make sure you
register at
thinkmasterclass.com and at the end of
that we're going to tell you how you can
join us inside of one of the fastest
growing online communities right now for
youtubers thank you so much for
listening to today's episode and we'll
catch you in the next one bye